but first my thoughts on America and
shut down day 51 now it's hard to
imagine that there are actually people
out there who seem happier when most of
America is miserable and conversely
they're miserable when most of you are
happy but that sums up things on the
left in the age of Trump and especially
during this unprecedented Kovach crisis
now with the pandemic as a kind of cover
they're excited about ramming through
this new vision for a new America and
I'm not just talking about one where we
wash our hands as often as we should or
coffin to our elbows the goal here is to
remake America into a progressive
society supposedly a more equitable
society we're not going back to normal
it's back to a new normal and we may
never have the normal that we had prior
to cold mid-nineteen let's take this
experience and really learn how we can
do differently and better with our
education system in terms of technology
and virtual education now let's face it
these people a lot of them at least
didn't like the old normal why because
in the old normal the people elected
Donald Trump today the New York Times
published a shockingly honest op-ed
about what really irks the left about
traditional America one word freedom
open states lots of guns America is
paying a heavy price for freedom the
title read and in predictable fashion
columnist Charlie Worzel praises
Europe's more enlightened approach to
lockdowns and complains that were just
too free for own darn good americans who
question mandates on mask-wearing are
stupid selfish and dangerous
just like those gun rights advocates
this is what he says in this narrow
worldview freedom has a price it's a
price that will be calculated and then
set by a select few the rest of us
merely pay it
dun-dun-duh Wow wait the
actually complaining about a select few
setting the rules but isn't this how the
left prefers it they certainly don't
prefer rule by the people people who
still believe in Italy's quaint things
like the first and second amendments the
left prefers rule by a few maybe a few
billionaire technocrats or by unelected
bureaucrats and by liberal governors who
prolong these shutdowns without
legislative oversight at all the entire
of the people by the people for the
people thing hasn't really delivered
that progressive utopia that the left so
desperately desires but maybe just maybe
the pandemic will there is a primordial
American tradition going back to the
founders of being freedom obsessed even
though we're a country founded on
slavery and genocide that we are blind
to other types of threats whether it's a
virus whether it's bank malfeasance or
what have climate change what have you
now let that sink in we are freedom
obsessed yes I am guilty as charged
freedom obsessed most people want to go
on with their lives you get the sense
you can see it around you they
understand that walking out the door
every day entails risks sometimes
serious ones the old normal to them
means little league in high school proms
graduations it means church on Sunday or
other types of worship and work on
Monday
it means dinner with friends and family
vacations every now and then of course
it is a horrible tragedy that so many
Americans had to die because of this
virus that started in China it's awful
but it would be an even worse tragedy if
we lost our country because of it we can
never bring back those we've lost but we
can try to repair the cultural and
economic damage before it's too late
this is how Barron's described the old
normal you know that normal at the end
of 2019 before the coronavirus
households are in good
shape unemployment is at half century
lows wages have been increasing faster
than inflation and consumer confidence
remains near its highs of the cycle that
likely help shoppers feel particularly
jolly this holiday season and they open
their wallets to celebrate seems like a
long time ago now doesn't it but rather
than being happy that Americans were
doing so well just a few months back the
airheads in the liberal media just
became more bitter it seems Democrats
became more committed to impeaching
Trump at the time and the American Left
became frankly just more unhinged as
most in the country were enjoying life
pre kovat Trump's adversaries were
engulfed in anger and resentment their
faces told the story Pelosi Schumer
Schiff Waters and then there were the
Trump hating TV anchors and pundits
pretending to be journalists they all
felt dejected and demoralized Nicole
Wallace Don Lemon Chuck Todd Jake Tapper
but now they kind of see their opening
re-energized reorganized maybe
reinventing so what do we need to do to
make sure that we actually help real
people and that goes for renters but it
also goes for mom-and-pop landlords you
know one of the first things that we
talk about which is our first demand is
rent cancellation I mean she's just I've
never seen her happier I mean she looked
like glowing before they argued that
Trump was Putin's puppet remember now
they say he's a murderer for not being
more like Putin and ordering the nation
to close remember in their utopia you
may get free bread milk but you won't
have your freedom my friends they'll
call the shots
you'll be traced and tracked not just
for viruses but in every aspect of your
life
you don't believe me let's take a look
at the place they're praising for its
responsible response to the virus China
it has begun a bold mass experiment and
using data to regulate citizens lives by
requiring them to use software on their
smartphones that dictates whether they
should be quarantined or allowed into
subways malls or other public spaces
this is all being done for your own good
of course that's what the left wants you
to think but is that what really
Americans want those are my thoughts at
the end of day 51 America in shutdown